good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can improve
as a public speaker let me first make it
very clear that everyone in this room is
a speaker you guys get that do you have
an idea that you want someone to get at
times you really want them to get you
yes your speaker you got a project you
want someone to understand and get on
board with your speaker you have a
business you would like to succeed
you're really a speaker let's not
mention platform speaking it's just any
business your speaker anything no one
can market you and your project better
than you and you got to do it through
your language
I'd like to suggest that there are four
really powerful cornerstones foundations
that we can stand on if we want our
speech to be powerful and to make change
in the world fortunately these things
spell a word the word is hail and it has
a great definition as well I'm not
talking about the stuff that falls from
the sky and hits you on the head I'm
talking about this definition to greet
or acclaim enthusiastically which is I
think how our words will be received if
we stand on these four things so what do
they stand for see if you can guess the
H honesty of course being true in what
you say being straight and clear the a
is authenticity just being yourself a
friend of mine described it as standing
in your own truth which i think is a
lovely way to put it
the i' is integrity being your word
actually doing what you say and being
somebody people can trust and the L is
love I don't mean romantic love but I do
mean wishing people well for two reasons
first of all I think absolute honesty
may not be what we want I mean my
goodness you look ugly this morning and
perhaps that's not necessary tempered
with love of course honesty is a great
thing but also if you're really wishing
somebody well it's very hard to judge
them at the same time I'm not even sure
you can do those two things
simultaneously
so hail also now that's what you say and
it's like the old song it is what you
say it's also the way that you say it
you have an amazing toolbox this
instrument is incredible and yet this is
a toolbox that very few people have ever
opened I'd like to have a little rummage
in there with you now just pull a few
tools out that you might like to take
away and play with which will increase
the power of your speaking register for
example now falsetto register may not be
very useful most of the time but there's
a register in between I'm not going to
get very technical about this for any of
you who are voice coaches you can locate
your voice however so if I talk up here
in my nose you can hear the difference
if I go down here and my throat which is
where most of us speak from most of the
time but if you want wait you need to go
down here to the chair
you hear the difference we vote for
politicians with lower voices it's true
because we associate depth with power
and with authority
that's register and we have Tambor it's
the the way your voice feels again the
research shows that we prefer voices
which are rich smooth warm like hot
chocolate well if that's not you that's
not the end of the world because you can
train go get a voice coach and there are
amazing things you can do with breathing
with posture with exercises to improve
the timbre of your voice then pros are
the aisle of pros idli this is the sinks
on the meta language that we use in
order to impart meaning it's route 1 for
meaning in conversation people who speak
all on one notes are really quite hard
to listen to if they don't have any
prose idea at all that's where the words
monotonic comes from or not honest
monotone also we have repetitive prose
that he now coming in where every
sentence ends as if it were a question
when it's actually not a question it's a
statement
and if you repeat that one over and over
it's actually restricting your ability
to communicate through prose adiy which
i think is a shame so let's try and
break that habit pace I can get very
very excited by saying something really
really quickly or I can slow right down
to emphasize and at the end of that of
course is our old friend silence it's
nothing wrong with a bit of silence you
know talk is there we don't have to fill
it with ohms and ours can be very
powerful
of course pitch often goes along with
pace to indicate arousal but you can do
it just with pitch where did you leave
my keys where did you leave my keys it's
a slightly different meaning in those
two deliveries and finally volume I can
get really excited by using volume sorry
about that if I startled anybody or I
can have you really pay attention make
it very quiet
some people broadcast the whole time try
not to do that
that's called sod casting
imposing your sound on people around you
carelessly and inconsiderately not nice
of course where this all comes into play
most of all is when you've got something
really important to do it might be
standing on a stage like this and giving
a talk to people it might be proposing
marriage asking for a raise a wedding
speech whatever it is if it's really
important you owe it to yourself to look
at this tool box and the engine that
it's going to work on and no engine
works well without being warmed up warm
up your voice I'd like to share with you
one of the little known secrets of the
top professional speakers and it is
called the power of the pause now in
speaking the drama and power of the
speech is contained in the silences that
you create as you move from point to
point and this is an art that you can
learn with practice many speakers are
nervous when they stand up in front of
an audience as a result they speak
faster with a higher pitch to their
voice and without pausing when you are
more relaxed you speak slower you pause
regularly and you have a deeper and more
authoritative tone of voice as either a
man or a woman now there's nothing as
attention-grabbing
as a pause when you pause you bring
people up short they mentally trip and
fall into the silence that you have
created they immediately give you back
their full attention each time you pause
go silent smile you get them to recenter
themselves on you and what you are
saying but for instance the dramatic
pause is used to make a particular point
stick in the minds of your audience you
can use a dramatic pause immediately
before delivering an important point and
you can use a dramatic pause immediately
afterwards to allow people to absorb the
importance of what you just said for
example I would say there are three keys
to your doubling your income in the next
six months
if you practice these keys nothing can
stop you from earning more money than
you've ever earned before key number one
is this and you start and at the end you
stop key number two is this and then you
start and describe it and then you stop
and at the end you just stop and allow
people to absorb another pause you can
use is called the sentence completion
pause this should be illegal because
it's so powerful and this is where you
make a statement or quote a line that
everyone has heard before and knows the
words when you give the first half of
the line or even nine-tenths of the line
the audience mentally leans forward to
complete the sentence with you this
causes them to engage more closely with
you and to listen with greater in
tenderness to what you're saying now
whenever you use this technique you must
discipline yourself to stop and wait
until the audience speaks up and
completes the sentence you then repeat
the words to finish the thought you'll
have the total attention of the audience
here's an example of what I do I'm
talking about selling and running a
business in competitive times and I say
but you're not afraid of that because
when the going gets tough that tough get
going everybody in the audience
completes the sense they really for the
go going they're always staining they
don't necessarily speak aloud but they
finish this sentence in your mind their
mind so it's very powerful technique you
can use most people vision when they're
telling a story they don't want to take
a risk so the story has it has its
limits on how high it will go or how
deep it ago and when you have that then
you're really not at that part that's
gonna touch my soul so being willing to
take a risk being clear and concise with
your stories a great story is a ShowMe
story not a tell me story now this is
the distinction that's the game changer
for most most people were telling a
story they say so let me just share with
you a little bit of my story and I'll
tell you and then I'll show you
so as I was building my life there was a
time in my life that was very difficult
it was very challenge true story very
difficult very challenging very
uncomfortable I didn't have a lot of
money I didn't have a lot of hope and
things just look dismal at some point I
had to turn my life around at some point
I made the decision that life had to get
better I'm telling you that was decent
you learn about me then if I were to
show you that story I would say six days
a week I had to eat beanies and weenies
I had to find money in the crevices and
the corners of my couch so that I can
get my son milk there were times when my
heart would beat fast just at what am I
gonna have tomorrow at some point I got
sick and tired of my own story is this
gonna be my future no I can't handle it
notice the difference in that second
story I completely see that I just
painted a picture same story now the
second one will you show a story it's
gonna require more of you it's gonna
require to find the colors what were you
thinking what were you experiencing what
was going on in your head instead of
telling me you look for money turn and
point now this is anywhere this is
anywhere you are doing anything I
promise you become a great storyteller
and you will have to bait your audience
no matter what you're doing I've
captivated investors I've captivated
students I've captivated educators
because I was willing to show the story
I call it unpacking the story vision
being willing to tell me what were you
thinking what were you feeling
what were you saying think about a story
as an oral movie and so in an oral movie
think when you're looking at a movie the
first thing they do is they identify
what state of time it is is a futuristic
is it in the now or is it back in the
day you notice that based on what people
are wearing how they're talking so paint
that picture for me take me to that
environment set the backdrop up for me
show me what you're going through
instead of saying I was angry you can
tell me you're angry but when you say
the hair on the back of my neck was
standing up I felt the fumes exiting my
nose I thought that my chest was going
to pop and I was gonna say something
that I'd regret forever ooh
just showed me you were angry take that
extra time to unpack it
why will most people not do that because
it requires a level of vulnerability
that we're not willing to share we all
know the maxim that practice makes
perfect but what's most important is
that we're practicing in specific ways
what we want to do is actually speak as
much of our presentation as we can we
actually want to speak in front of a
mirror or in front of a webcam that way
we can see ourselves succeeding moreover
we can also be attentive to what we do
well and what we can improve one of the
most important parts the presentation to
practice is the introduction and the
conclusion the audience will be drawn in
by the introduction and hopefully we'll
be left with something to think about
when it comes time for the conclusion I
want to emphasize that there's a real
joy in stepping out in front of an
audience
a real excitement that comes from
sharing one's passion with a group of
people so we can't let the fear of
public speaking paralyze us and inhibit
our abilities to get to the next step to
get to the type of positions that we
want and that we're ready for would you
have fun show some enthusiasm show some
passion in the 2007 presentation Steve
Jobs was having fun he was laughing he
had a big smile on his face
animated body language it was really
wonderful to see he even played a prank
on Starbucks he was demonstrating the
new maps feature on the phone ironically
it was Google Maps and I know there's
been some controversy since then but he
was showing off Google Maps and he was
demonstrating just how easy it was to
find a location and contact that
location
so we looked for a local Starbucks a
coffee shop around the venue which he
was speaking he actually found the
number called Starbucks a woman on the
other end answered and said good morning
yes I'd like to order 4,000 lattes to go
please not just kidding
wrong number thank you I actually called
the number that I saw flashed on the
screen sure enough it went to a local
Starbucks in San Francisco he actually
pranked a Starbucks now I'm not
suggesting you prank anybody in your
next presentation of course not but you
the idea would you have some fun most
presentations are really really dry and
boring Steve Jobs had passion enthusiasm
and he showed it so I have two quick
thoughts on this the first is you need
to practice you need to practice you
need to practice you need to practice
you need to practice you need to
practice I think a lot of people they
see the challenge of they look at a Tony
Robbins they see a Les Brown they see an
Eric Thomas and you see how great these
guys are and you know what a good public
speaker looks like because you've
watched their videos you've been to
their events you've seen them live and
then you get up on stage and you know
that you're nothing like them you're
nowhere close to being like them and
it's an unfair comparison because
they've spent decades practicing and you
might be just getting started and so the
way to get there is to practice and
practice and practice and practice and I
think too many people look to those
other people and it's great to look at
them for inspiration it's great to look
at them to model success I love it it's
the name of this channel but don't let
that be a discouragement the flip side
is people see how great somebody else is
and they feel like I can't get there
because you're comparing your start to
somebody else's middle and so practice
practice practice just make sure you are
better than you were yesterday
the second thing is going in with the
intent to help them and know that you
can provide value I think it's easy to
get on stage and be so locked into your
presentation and memorizing the exact
words that you're going to say and were
they gonna make a mistake for me it's
just going up and I just came back from
Madrid recently it's going up on stage
and having the intent to give them value
to know that what I have what's in my
head can help them like to genuinely
feel like I have knowledge that can help
them all I need to do is get it out and
not be so worried about saying the exact
thing that you have written down but
just letting it feel through you leading
it with intent leading it with emotion
and if you can get on the stage and just
feel like you want to help these guys
instead I memorize your presentation
you're gonna have much more success as a
public speaker and one quick tip that
really helps me with that is I always
try to talk to people before so it's not
some
cold audience that I know nothing about
I try to meet people ask them what
they're up to I talk about their
business I talked about challenges
they're facing and so I imagine that
person I'll try to find them in the
audience too when I'm speaking it makes
it a lot more personal for me and when I
know that it's personal I'm much more
likely to be able to connect not with
just with them but with the whole
audience
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this episode of believe life
because my videos asked me to so this is
topic you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of believed life leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know one what your
favorite clip was from here that you
learn the most from and - what are your
fears or concerns or thoughts about
public speaking that maybe I can help
you with and the rest of the leave
nation can join in the conversation as
well leaving the comments below I'll
join in thank you guys so much for
watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you soon
your ability to speak effectively in
every business or social situation can
have an extraordinary effect on your
life it can bring you to the attention
of people who can help you and open
doors for you it can get you better jobs
and get you promoted faster most of all
your ability to give effective
presentations both to small and large
groups will increase your own feeling of
self esteem self-respect and personal
pride when you know that you can
influence and persuade others in a
variety of ways you'll have a tremendous
sense of personal power and
accomplishment
you'll feel like a master of any
situation and the best news of all is
that these skills are learn about with
practice and repetition and because
they're learning it means there's no
limits on how good you can become